para combatir el calor esta escuela de
la región occidental del país de la luz
está en alerta máxima los sombreros son
obligatorios y las actividades diarias
se han modificado para evitar la
insolación los profesores rocían a los
niños con agua y se aseguran de que se
mantengan alejados del sol
[Música]
busquets
así calma
muchos padres optaron por dejar a sus
hijos en casa o vinieron a recogerlos al
mediodía
esta mañana fueron a la escuela el calor
aún era manejable pero esta tarde
organizado las cosas con el trabajo para
poder quedarme en casa y ellos también
están aquí si las temperaturas han
superado la barrera de los 40 grados en
algunas zonas de francia al menos 13
zonas registraron las temperaturas más
altas de la historia para esta época del
año en antibes ciudad costera de la
costa azul hace más que calor
vivimos en el campo y los depósitos de
agua están empezando a secarse esto no
suele ocurrir nunca y es preocupante
pues
casi nadie sale a la calle y la mayoría
de personas han cerrado sus casas pero
algunos no pueden permitirse el lujo de
quedarse en casa como estos trabajadores
que cuidan los jardines públicos en
toulouse
hay que tener cuidado de no excederse
uno se puede marear muy fácilmente
hay que tener cuidado tengo varios
colegas que se enfermaron hace tanto
calor que vomitaron y algunos se
desmayaron
este mensajero en bicicleta decidió irse
a casa por el día
me voy a casa porque ahora es difícil ir
en bicicleta es la ola de calor más
temprana registrada en francia desde
1947 las temperaturas siguen subiendo y
deberían alcanzar su punto máximo el
sábado antes de que empiecen a bajar
según las previsiones a partir del
domingo